this one is for our local seniors center
well senior primary care the sponsors of
this next segment want to help you stay
healthy especially during the holidays
dr [ __ ] welcome to las vegas now
hi thanks for having me thank you for
joining us and doing all the things you
do for the community at center well so
tell us about center well and what you
guys do
yeah so central is a senior focused
primary care center um designed for
patients 65 and older
and we've been in the valley for a few
years now and it's been such a privilege
to care for so many of our community
seniors
absolutely especially during this time
and i know you guys have
multiple locations around the valley so
what do each what does each team provide
to the community at each of your
locations
yeah so every center well has its own
care team and that includes a doctor
nurses behavioral health specialists a
clinical pharmacist and more
and we all work together to maximize the
care that seniors can receive in one
convenient location
so each patient has a full care team
working together to keep them healthy
i love it and let's talk more about
senior focused care what does that mean
to you guys
yeah so it really starts with training
the entire care team um to serve seniors
it includes convenient locations shorter
wait times
doctors visits that don't feel rushed
fun social activities for seniors and
more um and as a doctor i'm able to
spend more time with my patients because
the better i get to know them the better
i can care for them i love that it's so
good to not feel rushed you know in a
doctor's appointment to feel cared about
genuinely um you know how can people
become patients with you guys
so it's actually very simple to become a
patient at center well um just stop by
one of our eight locations throughout
the valley and we can give you a tour of
our center and help you schedule your
first appointment we're always ready to
say hello to new patients that are
looking for quality care
perfect and of course it is the holiday
season
is any health tips for our seniors as
they as they celebrate with their
families
yeah so the pandemic has changed some
holiday traditions for many of us um but
it's important to remember you can still
safely enjoy this time with your family
and friends um so if you're eligible for
the copic vaccine we strongly recommend
that you and those around you be
vaccinated um it's important to continue
to wear a mask and keep your distance
and it's also important to be mindful of
your diet during the holidays so
watching your sugar and salt intake
closely
we usually recommend to enjoy but don't
over indulge
and uh if you're able to try to skip
having seconds of dessert
this is this is great advice for anybody
not just seniors right
well thank you so much dr [ __ ] we
appreciate you and center well thank you
so much
all right thank you center well senior
primary care for sponsoring this segment
if you'd like more information just head
to centerwell lasvegas.com